the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I've worked hard over the weekend
figured out what I was doing last time
and what I'm doing this time and
improved the notes so you'll get a new
set of notes on the last lecture and on
this one and I kind of got to got a
better picture of what we're doing and
that board is aiming to describe the
large picture of what we're doing last
time and this time so last time was
about changes in a inverse when a
changed this time is about changes in
eigenvalues and changes in singular
values when a changes you can imagine
this is a natural important situation
matrices move and therefore their
inverses change their eigenvalues change
their singular values change and it you
hope for a formula well so we did have a
formula for last time for the change in
the inverse matrix so that's and I
didn't get every U and V transpose in
the right place in the video but or in
the first version of the notes but I
hope that there'll be the formula that
that Woodberry morrison formula will be
correct
this time ok so so I won't go back over
that part
but I realize also there there's another
question that we can answer when the
change is very small when the change in
a is da or Delta a of a small change and
that's of course what calculus is about
so I have to sort of parallel topics
here what is the derivative when the
changes of of it is infinitesimal and
what is the actual change when the
change is finite size okay so now let me
say what we can do and what we can't do
for oh I'll start out by figuring out
what the derivative is for the inverse
so that's like completing the last time
for infinitesimal changes then I'll move
on to changes in the eigenvalues and
singular values and there you cannot
expect an exact formula we had a we had
a formula that was exact apart from any
typos for this and we'll find a formula
for this and we'll find a formula for
that and for that well that one will
come from this one so so this will be a
highlight today how do the eigen values
change when the matrix changes but we
won't be able to do parallel to this we
won't be able to oh well we will be able
to do something for finite changes
that's important the mathematics would
have to keep hitting it that problem
until it got somewhere so I won't get an
exact formula for the change that's too
much but I'll get inequalities how big
that change could be what can I say
about it so these are that's highly
interesting may I start with the
completing the last lecture what
the derivative of the inverse so I'm
thinking here so what's the setup the
setup is my matrix a depends on time on
T and it has an inverse a inverse
depends on T and if I know this
dependence in other words if I know da
DT how much what how the matrix is
depending on T then I hope I could
figure out what the derivative of a
inverse is that we should be able to do
this so let me just start with the it's
not hard and it complements this one by
doing the calculus case the the
infinitesimal change so I want to get to
that I'm given I'm given I can figure
out the change in a and my job is to
find a change the derivative of this a
and of a inverse okay so here's a handy
identity and I just put this here so
here's my useful identity I want to so
as last time I start with a with a
finite change its calculus always does
that right starts with a delta T and
then it goes to zero so so here I'm up
at the full size change so I think that
this is equal to B inverse a minus B a
inverse and that's if it's true it's a
pretty cool formula and look it is true
because over on this right hand side I
have B inverse times a a
versus the identity so that's my B
inverse and I have the minus the B
inverse B is the identity there is a
inverse it's good right so so that is a
from that well we I could actually learn
from that the the rank of this equals
the rank of this that's that's a point
that I made from the big formula but now
we can see it from easy formula I'm
assuming that B and a everywhere here
I'm assuming that a and b are invertible
matrices so when i multiply by an
invertible matrix that does not change
the rank so the those have the same rank
but I'm gonna get further than that I
want to find this okay so how do I go
how do I go forward with that job to
find the derivative of the universe well
I'm gonna let I'm gonna call this a
change in a inverse and over here
I'll have V will be yeah okay see right
yeah so B inverse will be this is really
this is a plus Delta a inverse and this
is well that's a minus B so that's
really minus Delta a minus right
the change is from A to B is the change
here I'm looking at this the difference
a minus B so it's minus a change and
here I have a inverse I haven't done
anything except to introduce this Delta
for the and get me out of it and brought
Delta in okay now I want to do
calculations
so I'm thinking of B as being you know a
little a little there's a sort of a
delta T and I'm gonna divide by both
sides by delta T I have to do this if I
want and now I'll let Delta T go to zero
so this is calculus appears finally are
I won't say our enemy calculus but but
there's a sort of like competition
between linear algebra and calculus for
for college mathematics calculus has had
far far too much time and attention it's
like it gets three or four semesters of
calculus for people who don't get any
linear algebra I'm glad this won't be on
the video but I'm afraid it will anyway
of course calculus is fine in its place
okay so here's its place now let Delta t
go to zero so what does this equation
become it just ends and everybody knows
that as the limit as delta T goes to
zero I replace Delta's by the Delta so
this Delta a divided by delta T that has
a meaning each the top has a meaning and
the bottom has a mean but then in the
limit it's a ratio that has a meaning so
da by itself
I don't attach a meaning to that's
infinitesimal it's the limit so that's
why I wanted a delta over a delta so I
could do calculus so what happens now as
delta T goes to zero and of course as
delta T goes to zero that carries Delta
a to zero so that becomes a inverse and
what does this approach as delta T goes
to zero
da/dt with that minus sign oh I've got
to remember the minus sign minus sign is
in here - I'm bringing out the minus
sign then this was a inverse as we had
and that da/dt and that's a inverse
that's our formula a nice formula which
sort of belongs in people's knowledge
you recognize that if a was a 1 by 1
matrix we could call it X instead of a
if a if a there's a 1 by 1 matrix X then
I'm seeing the formula for the
derivative of 1 over X write a inverse
just a 1 by 1 case it's just 1 over X so
the derivative of 1 or maybe T I should
be saying if if a is just T then the
derivative of 1 over T with respect to T
is is minus 1 over T squared right I've
just the one by one case we know that's
what calculus does and now we're able to
do that n by n case so that's that's
just like good and then it's it sir
parallel to formulas like this which are
where this delta a is not gone to 0 it's
full size but low-rank
that was the point actually the formula
would be it would apply if the rank
wasn't low but the interest is in low
rank
are we good for this that's really the
completion of last times lecture with
with derivatives ok ok come in come back
to here to the new thing now lambdas
let's focus on lambdas eigenvalues how
does the eigen value change when the
matrix changes how does the eigen value
change when the matrix changes so I have
to
possibilities one is small change when
I'm doing calculus and I'm letting a
delta T go to zero the other is full
size order one change where I will not
be able to give you a formula for the
new lambdas but I'll be able to tell you
important facts about them so that's so
this is this is today's lecture now you
could say that's the completion of
Friday's lecture what about D lambda DT
it's a nice formula and it's a proof is
fun - I was very happy about this proof
okay so I guess calculus is showing up
here on this middle board so how do I
start with the eigenvalues well start
with what I know so so these are facts
you could say that I have to get the
eigenvalues into it and of course
eigenvalues have to come with eigen
vectors so I'll again use a of T it'll
be depending on T and an eigen vector
that depends on T is an eigen value that
depends on T times an eigen vector that
depends on T great a fact one that we
plan to take the derivative of somehow
there's also a second fact that comes
into play here what's the deal on the
eigenvalues of a transpose they're the
same the eigenvalues of a transpose are
the same as the eigen values of a are
the eigenvectors the same not usually of
course if the matrix was symmetric then
a and a transpose are just the same
thing so they would have so a transpose
would have that eigenvalue but generally
eigenvector but it generally it has a
different eigenvector and it really to
keep it sort of separate from this one
let's call it y it'll have the same
eigenvalue I'm going to call
why but I'm gonna make it a row vector
because a transpose is what instead of
writing down a transpose I'm gonna stay
with a but put the eigenvalue on the
left side so here here's the eigenvalue
eigenvector for a on the left and it has
the same eigenvalue times that
eigenvector but that i in vector is a
row I am very of course this is an
equality between rows a row times my
matrix gives a row so that's the
eigenvalues of that it has the same
eigenvalue so this is this is totally
parallel to that totally parallel and
maybe there's sort of less definitely
less seen but it's just the same thing
for a transpose you use everybody sees
if I transpose this equation then I've
got something that looks like that but
I'd rather have it this way now one more
thing about these one more fact I need
there's there has to be some I some
normalization how long how what should
be the length of the right now X could
have any lengths Y could have any length
and there's a natural normalization
which is y transpose times X equal to
one that normalizes the to doesn't tell
me the length of X or the length of Y
but it tells me the key saying they're
lengths of both so what I've what I've
got there is tracking along one eigen
value and it's pair of eigen vectors and
you're always welcome to think of the
symmetric case when y and X are the same
and then I would call them Q oh well I
would call them Q if it was a symmetric
matrix but I would have if yeah so if
it's a symmetric matrix I would call the
both eigenvectors would be called q
and this would be saying that queue is a
unit vector right so this is all stuff
we know and actually maybe I should
write it in in matrix notation just so
cuz it's important so if that's for one
eigenvector this is for all of them at
once everybody's with it the x's are the
columns of X and I need to mull aMDA is
the diagonal matrix of lambdas and it
has to sit on the right so that it will
multiply those columns so this is like
all all eigenvectors at once
what would this one be this would be
like Y transpose a equals a Y transpose
Y s equals o and probably these are
multiplied it's funny I don't want to
put what I'm I feel wrong if I write Y
transpose here like here the X was on
the right and on the left and album one
oh it yeah y transpose yeah okay so what
do I put lambda Y transpose and what do
I put here what does this translate to
if I if this was for a one eigenvector
for all of them at once it's just gonna
translate to Y transpose X equal the
identity this is pretty basic stuff but
stuff somehow we don't always
necessarily see okay those are the key
facts and now I plan to take the
derivative take the derivative with
respect to lambda oh okay I can derive
one more fact so this
formula this is formula one formula one
just says what do I get if I hit this on
the left by Y transpose can I do that Y
transpose of T a of T X of T equals
lambda of T that's us that's a number so
I can always bring that out but in front
of the inner product the vector notation
are you good for that I'm pleading like
everything I've done is totally okay and
now I have a improvement to make on this
right hand side which is so what is y
transpose times X it's 1 so let's
remember that it's 1 so in other words I
have got a formula for lambda of T the
eigen value as time changes the matrix
changes its eigen values change
according to this formula its
eigenvectors change according to this
formula and it's left eigenvectors
change according to that formula isn't
that so where everything here is
aboveboard and now what's the point
the point is I'm gonna find this the
derivative so I'm going to take the
derivative of that equation and see what
I get
that's that'll be the formula for the
derivative of an eigen value and it's
it's amazingly it's not that widely
known it's of course it's classical but
it's not always part of courses so these
this is as time varies the matrix varies
a and therefore its eigenvalues
and it's eigenvectors very so we're
gonna find D lambda DT it's one level of
difficulty more to find DX DT that the
derivative of the eigenvector or the
second derivative of the eigenvalue
though those kind of come together and
I'm not gonna go there I'm just gonna do
the one great thing here take the
derivative of that equation shall I do
it over there so here we go so I want to
compute D lambda DT and I'm using this
formula for lambda there so I've got
three things that depend on T and I'm
taking the derivative of their product
so I'm gonna use the product rule right
now it takes a I'll apply the product
rule to that derivative okay
take the derivative of the first guy
times a times X take the derivative of
the second guy times the second guy and
the third guy Y transpose of T a of T DX
DT okay we are one minute away from a
great formula and I'm really happy if
you allow me to say it that that the
formula comes by just putting taking
those facts we know putting them
together into this expression that we
also know and that this is like lambda
equals X inverse ax
that's diagonalizing thing and then
taking the derivative so what do I get
if I take that derivative well this term
I'm going to keep like I'm not going to
play with that everybody's clear that's
a number here's a matrix the ADT is a
matrix the derivative I take the
derivative of it every entry in a here's
it's a column vector its eigen vector
and here's a row vector so Rho times
matrix times column is a number one by
one and actually that's my answer
that's my answer so I'm saying that
these two terms cancel each other out
those two terms add to zero and that
this is the right answer for for the
derivative
that's a nice formula so to find the
derivative of an eigen value you take
the rate the matrix is changing you
multiply by the Oregon vector and by the
left eigen vector it gives you a number
and that's the D lambda DT okay so why
do those two guys add to zero that's
that's all that remains here and then
this topic is ended with this nice
formula okay so I want to simplify that
simplify that and show that they cancel
each other okay so what is ax its lambda
X so this guy is nothing but it's lambda
that depends on time of course times dy
DT D Y transpose DT I'm just copying
that ax is lambda X
sorry I didn't mean to make that look
hard okay with that ax is lambda X and I
am perfectly safe because lambda is just
a number to bring it out to the left so
it's not getting doesn't look like it's
in the way and what about this other
term so I have y transpose au y
transpose a what's that what's Y
transpose a that's the combination that
I know Y transpose a a a let Y is that
left eigenvector y transpose a is brings
out a lambda so this also brings out a
lambda times y transpose x dx/dt okay I
just use ax equal lambda X there that
was really nothing now what do I do
can you I want this to be zero can you
see it happening it's a it's a great
pleasure to see it happening so what do
I have here what's my first step now
bring would bring lambda outside that's
not zero we don't know what that is
bring lambda outside there times the
whole thing so for some wonderful reason
I believe that this number which is a
roll times at column a row times a
column two terms there I believe they
knock each other out and they that
result is zero and why why because I
come back to the this is this board has
all that I know and here's why transpose
times X equal one and how does that help
me because what I'm seeing in that
square in that and those brackets is the
derivative of Y transpose X
so it's the derivative of one therefore
zero so this is the derivative of one it
equals zero those two terms knock each
other out and leave just the nice term
that we're seeing so the derivative of
the eigenvalue just just to have one
more look at it before we leave it the
derivative of the eigenvalue is this
formula it's the rate at which the
matrix is changing times the
eigenvectors on right and left sometimes
they're called the right eigenvector in
the left eigenvector at at the time t
yeah so a is so we're not seeing in this
d lambda DT in other words does is not I
don't need to I get a nice formula which
doesn't involve the derivative of the
eigenvector that's the beauty of it if I
want to go up should take the next step
I tried this weekend but it's a mess if
it would be to take there so I've this
is my formula and D lambda DT equals
this and I can take the next derivative
of that and it will involve the second
day DT squared right but it will also
involve DX DT and dy DT and it in fact
the pseudo-inverse even shows up it's
it's a another step and I'm not going
that far because we've got the the best
formula there okay so now that has
answered this question and I could
answer that question the same way it
would involve a transpose a and the
singular vectors instead of involving a
and the eigenvectors maybe that's a
suitable exercise I don't know I haven't
done it myself what I want to do is this
now now it's say what can we say about
the change in the eigenvalue and I'll
just stay first of all with eigenvalues
when the change is like Rank 1 that way
this is a perfect example when the
change is Rank 1 so so so I'm really so
what can we say about the eigenvalues
let's take the top the largest
eigenvalue or all of them all of them
lambda J all of them of a plus a rank
one matrix UV transpose oh let me make
it let's let's do the nice case here a
nice case because if I allow a general
matrix a I have to worry about does it
have enough eigenvectors you know can it
diagonalize all that stuff let's make
let's make it a symmetric matrix and
let's make the rank one change symmetric
too so the question is what can I say
about the eigenvalues of after a rank
one change so again this isn't calculus
now because the change that I'm making
is as fully as is a true vector and not
a differential okay and I'm not going to
have an exact formula for the new eigen
values as I said but what I am going to
do is write down the beautiful facts
that are known about that and here they
are so first of all the eigen values are
in descending order we use descending
order for singular values let's use them
also for an eigen value so lambda 1
is greater equal to lambda 2 greater
equal lambda 3 and so on
Oh give me give me a yeah give me an
idea well what do you expect from from
that rank one change so that that
changes Rank 1 can you tell me any more
about that change you you transpose what
kind of a matrix is uu transpose it's
rank 1 but we can say more
it is possum Ettrick of course and it is
yeah positive semi definite positive
semi definite this is a positive change
uu transpose is the typical rank 1
positive semi definite it couldn't be
positive definite because it's only got
Rank 1 what are the eigen what's the
eigenvector of that matrix yeah let's
just why not here we can do this in two
seconds
so uu transpose that's a matrix I'm
asking you to think about and it's a
full n by n matrix column times a row
tell me an eigenvector of that matrix
yes you if I multiply my matrix by you
I get what do I get I get some number
times U and what is that number lambda
is that lambda happens to be u transpose
U and what is the so that's different
from uu transpose this was a matrix
everybody uses 18 over 6 5 now that's a
number and what can you tell me about
that number
it is greater well even more greater
than 0 greater because this is a true
vector so this is greater than 0 it's
the only eigenvalue all the other
eigenvalues of the of that of that rank
one matrix are 0 but the one non-zero
eigen
value is over on the plus side it's you
transpose you we all recognize that as
the lengths of U squared it's certainly
positive so we do have a positive semi
definite matrix what would your guess be
of the effect on the eigenvalues of a so
so I'm coming back to my real problem I
can values of s sorry yes I have a
symmetric matrices I'm saying symmetric
what is your guess if I have a symmetric
matrix and I add on uu transpose what do
you imagine that does to the eigenvalues
you're gonna get it right just say it
what happens to the eigenvalues of s if
I add on uu transpose they will they'll
be more positive they'll go up this is a
positive thing it's like adding 17 to
something right it moves up so therefore
what I believe is so these now I have so
yeah I've got two sets of eigenvalues
now one is the argument of s the other
is the eigenvalues the different
eigenvalues of s so what I can't call
them both lambdas or I'm in trouble so
let me let me start so I'll call the
need so one other do you have a favorite
other Greek letter for the eigenvalues
of s gamma okay as long as you say a
Greek letters I have some idea how to
write Zeta it seems to me like the
world's toughest letter to write and
electrical engineers can coolly flush
alpha Zeta but like I've never succeeded
so so all right what did you say
gamma J of the original okay so those
are the eigenvalues of the original
these are the eigenvalues of the
modified and we're expecting the lambdas
to be big
than the gammas oh it's just a
qualitative statement and it's true
each lambda is bigger than the gamma oh
sorry yeah yeah each lambda by adding
this stuff the lambdas are bigger than
so I'll just write that lambdas are
bigger than gammas and that's a
fundamental fact which we could prove
but a little more is known of course the
question is how much bigger how much can
they be way bigger well I don't believe
they could be bigger by more than more
than that number myself but there's
there's there's better news than that so
the lambdas are bigger than the gammas
so lambda 1 is bigger than gamma 1 so
this is of this is the S Plus u u
transpose matrix and this these are the
eigenvalues of the S matrix lambda 1 is
bigger than gamma 1 but look what's
happening in this line of text here I'm
saying that gamma 1 that lambda 2 is
smaller than gamma 1 isn't that neat the
eigenvalues go up but they don't just
like go anywhere and that's called
interlacing
so this is one of those wonderful
theorems that makes your heart happy
that that the idea that if I do a rank
one change then the I and it's a
positive change then the eigen values
increase but they don't increase the new
eigen value is below the new second
eigen value it doesn't pass up the old
first eigen value and the new third
eigen value doesn't pass up the old
second eigen does yeah yeah so that's
the that's the interlacing theorem that
associated with the names of famous mass
guys that's just of course you have to
say that's beautiful while we're writing
down such a theorem make a guess of what
the theorem would be if I do a rank to
change suppose I do an A yes sorry s
staying symmetric and I do a rank one
change but then I also do a rank to
change say W w transpose okay so what's
the deal here what do I know about that
the change matrix the Delta s here I
know it's rank is 2 I'm assuming you and
W were not in the same direction so
that's a rank 2 matrix and what can you
tell me about the eigenvalues of that
Rank 2 matrix so it's got n eigenvalues
because it's an N by n matrix but how
many nonzero eigenvalues has it got too
because it's rank is to the rank tells
you the number of nonzero eigenvalues
when matrices are symmetric it doesn't
tell you enough if matrices are
unsymmetric eigenvalues can be weird so
stay symmetric here ok so that that
this has a Chazz two nonzero eigenvalues
and can you tell me their sign
what is that matrix positive
semi-definite yes of course it is of
course so this was and this was and
together it certainly is
so now I've added a rank two positive
definite positive semi definite matrix
and now just I'm not going to rewrite
this line but what would you expect to
be true you would expect the eigenvalues
increase but how big could lambda three
are sorry gamma yeah so gamma 2 let's
follow gamma 2 so so now well maybe I
should use another two the Greeks have
any other letters than lambda and gamma
who see all of that who knows that each
one I can write alpha good alpha yes
alpha right so alpha as the eigen alpha
is the eigenvalues of this this ring to
change okay now what am I going to be
able to say can I say anything about
this well of course alpha 1 is bigger
than lambda 1 which was bigger than I
mean I can measure going up right I'm
adding positive definite or positive
semi definite stuff there's no way I can
guys can start going down on me
so alpha 1 is greater or equal to the
lambda 1 which had just a rank one
change which is greater equal to the to
the MU was it mu gamma gamma 1 which is
a and that's yeah and so on okay now
let's see is alpha 1 is
one bigger than alpha what am i
struggling to to write down here well
what could I say well what can I say
that that reflects the fact that that
this lambda - no sorry
it reflects so gamma one went up who
camera one was bigger than lambda two
that was the point here gamma one is
bigger so so this was sort of easy
because I'm adding stuff I expected the
lambdas to go up this is where the
theorem is that it didn't go up so far
as to pass or sorry the the lambda two
which went up didn't pass up gamma 1
lambda 2 didn't pass up gamma 1 and now
let me write those words down now the
Alpha 2 well it could could alpha to
pass up lambda 1 and what about alpha 3
so so let me say what I believe I think
alpha 2 which is like 1 behind but I'm
adding rank - I think alpha 2 could pass
up lambda 1 it could pass lambda 1 but
alpha 3 can't I believe that alpha 3 is
smaller than lambda 1 so alpha 3 smaller
than then then gamma wasn't the original
yeah okay Oh anyway I'll get it right in
the notes you you you know what question
I'm asking and that's for me that's the
important thing
now there is a little matter of why is
this true this is the good case let me
give you another example of interlacing
can I do that it's it's it it really
comes from this but let me give you an
other example that's just striking so I
have a symmetric matrix n by n call it s
and then I throw away the last row and
column so in here is s n minus 1 the big
matrix was SN the this is a this one is
of size n minus 1 okay so it's got sort
of less degrees of freedom because the
last degree of freedom got removed and
what do you think about the eigenvalues
of this the N minus 1 eigenvalues of
this and the n eigenvalues of that they
interlace so the eigenvalues so so this
has eigen values lambda 1 this would
have an eigenvalue smaller than that
this would have an eigenvalue lambda 2
this would have an eigenvalue smaller
than that and so on just the same
interlacing and basically for the same
reason that when you like it's like it's
this is this this reduction to size n
minus 1 is like I'm saying xn has to be
0 in the energy or any any of those
expressions and the fact of making xn be
0 is a like a 1 constraint taking one
degree of freedom away it reduces the
eigen values but not by two okay now I
have one final mystery and let me try to
tell you what it worried me no what is
it that worried me yes
suppose this you that supposes this
change this u this change that I'm
making suppose it's actually the second
eigenvector of s so so can I kind of
write this down
suppose you is actually the second
eigenvector of s where I mean by that so
I mean that s times U is lambda 2 times
u okay okay now I look at and I'm gonna
change it s + uu transpose that's what
I've been looking at and that moves the
eigenvalues up but what worries me is
like if I multiply this by 20 some big
number I'm gonna move that eigenvalue
way up way past I'm like I got worried
about this this inequality right
if I but when I add this that's that
same U is lambda 2 plus 20 you write su
is lambda 2 u and this 20 is 20 U is a
unit vector so yes you see my worry here
I'm doing a Rank 1 change but it's moved
in eigen value way way up so how could
this danger this this statement be true
so I'm just I've just figured out here
what what gamete well yeah
you see my question I could leave it as
a question to answer next time let me do
that and I'll put it on online so you'll
see it clearly it looks like and it it
happens that this eigen vector now has
eigen value lambda 2 plus 20 why doesn't
that blow away this statement okay I'll
put that because it's sort of coming
with with minus 10 seconds to go in the
class so so let's leave that
a discussion of this for next time and
then but I'm happy with this lecture if
you are the last lecture I got using V's
mixed up and it's not reliable here I
like the proof of D lambda DT and we're
started on this topic - good thank you